even if you agree with removing the Lee
statue in Charlottesville which I don't
but even if you do you must at least
acknowledge that it is a historic
artifact it's literally registered as
one all of the controversy over it just
makes it more historically significant
so there's no valid reason to destroy it
you are literally destroying history
when you destroy it and the destruction
is a gratuitous act that can only be
meant to send an ideological and
political message and this goes well
beyond the Confederacy that's why the
mob quickly move from the Confederacy to
tearing down statues of of pretty much
any white person who happened to be born
prior to the 20th century even Teddy
Roosevelt fell victim what this tells us
is that leftists are preoccupied above
all with erasing the history and
traditions of this country it's about
power it's about dominating and
humiliating those that they identify as
the enemy and in large part they are
succeeding